I was browsing through the david pakman
show discussion forum earlier today at
david pakman.com slash reddit that's re
d di t i want to share with you some of
the interesting discussions that are
happening there number one don't
normalize george w bush a very
interesting article saying just because
bush seems more reasonable compared to
trump let's not pretend that bush was a
reasonable and sane president and i
completely agree with that and made that
point when we did the even Bush thinks
we need answers on russia story let's
not pretend bush with some great guy all
right also from our reddit discussion
forum an article posted about the 265
members of Congress who sold you out to
ISPs and how much it costs to buy them
breaking down the donations from the
cable and telecommunications industries
and lobbyists that were received by the
265 members of congress that voted in
favor of revoking the Obama era internet
privacy rules interesting article from
the verge also on our edit discussion
forum an article from the nation about
famine which could kill 20 million in
africa and yemen and yet we have
deafening silence and one of the
comments is because we have to repeal
obamacare which of course tells us a lot
about the priorities that we see from
our elected officials also on our reddit
discussion forum an interesting post
about belarus and russia which is
praising me for talking about belarus on
yesterday's show but saying i'm not
mentioning some of the protests that are
going on in Russia we can't mention
everything but we are making an effort
to cover a broad range of news and
continue covering both world news as
well as legislation related news in the
u.s. in the era of crazy crazy Trump
scandal so we're doing what we can and
lastly from our reddit discussion forum
today a viewer asking will keurig gate
never end and also saying that I am
absolutely right that ninety bucks for a
Keurig machine versus ten dollars for a
French press the key rig is not exactly
the populists caffeinating tool that
yesterday's voicemail caller suggested
it to be you know I'm officially
declaring Korea gate
to be over with they were like Sean
defied the investigation and luckily the
Chairman came to me with some new
revelations when Sean Spicer says Trump
Russia is over and we see that there's
three investigations going on it doesn't
matter that he called it over and as a
result I think clearly the audience has
spoken and Kira gate has not ended will
it ever end I don't know but we will see
join our discussion forum david
pakman.com slash r ed di t